- Okay, so Symone, you were
recently part of Hillary
and Chelsea Clinton's Gutsy.
- Yes.
- I, I love that whole series.
- Thank you.
- It was incredible.
- It was amazing, amazing.
- Yeah. I was so glad they, they came on.
Cause I got to watch the whole
thing and it was really cool.
How did that come about?
- Oh, hey wow look at that.
- Fabulous.
- Fabulous darling.
- Yeah.
- Pretty bitch.
All right.
- How did it-
How did it come about?
Like what, how did you
become a part of it?
- Oh, well, they, they sent an email.
You know how all these
things go and at first
my manager Hunter, he told me and I said,
Me is this a joke?
You playing with me?
He said, Yeah.
And then of course I was
honored and floored cuz I was
You do drag, you do all these things.
I've had a lot of great opportunities
but Hillary Clinton wanna come talk to me.
- It's Arkansas.
- She's from Arkansas.
Yeah. Yes.
- And we, we threw her a
party at our friend's house
back home.
We went to a prom drag show party
from Miss Hillary
Clinton, we did all of it.
- We did all of it.
- Did all of it.
I love that.
- Yeah. Like I perform in front of her.
It was great.
It was a fabulous experience.
- Yeah. The whole series was incredible.
I love that your highlighted
It was really, really cool.
I had to bring that up.